البشير يقر بمسؤوليته الكامله عن انقلاب
يونيو 89
بيومين فقط ميسي يهدم عرش البيضه الشهيره
غموض وحيره ماسك في موقف حرج استقاله ام
لا هذه الاخبار وغيرها منقولها لكم من
قناه العربيه طابت اوقاتكم
قرر رئيس السودانيه المعزول عمر البشير
بانه يتحمل المسؤوليه كامله عن انقلاب
الثلاثين من يونيو عام
1989 قائلا ان الاعتراف سيد الادله البشير
اعتبر في مرافعته خلال جلسه المحاكمه ان
التدخل القوات المسلحه انا ذاك كان بسبب
عجز السياسيين في اداره الشان العامه
مشددا على انه كان عمل عسكريا بحث ولم
يشارك فيها اي مدنيه في التخطيط او
التنفيذ
يبدو انا انجازات مسيله تنتهي قصادها
يتجاوز عالم الرياضه الى فضاءات اخرى
احدها انستقرام خلال يومين فقطع اصبحت
صوره ميسي التي نشرها على حسابه وهو يحمل
كاس العالم ضمن مجموعه صور اخرى المنشور
الاكثر حصدا للاعجابات في تاريخ انستغرام
عدد الاعجابات على منشور ميسي تجاوز 60
مليون والرقم في تزايد صاروخي وهو اعلى
بنحو اربعه ملايين من اعجابات سوره البينه
الشهيره التي كانت الاكثر بعدد الاعجابات
وعلى الاطلاق
عام 2019
نبقى في عالم منصات التواصل الاجتماعي لكن
هذه المره في تويتر حيث وجد الملياردير
الامريكيه والملكها الجديد ايلون ماسك
نفسه في موقف محرج بعد ان نشر استطلاع عن
حول تنحيه عن منصبه كرائيسا للمنصه نتيجه
الاستطلاع جاءت بتصويت
57.5% من المشاركين الذين فقع عددهم 17
مليون على تنحي ماسك بعد ذلك نقلت مواقع
اخباريه انماط تنحى فعلا لكن حقيقه ما
يزال الامر غامضه ولم يتضح حتى الان اذا
كان ماسك سيستقيل كما لم يغرد ولم يصدر اي
رد فعل على منصه تويتر حتى هذه اللحظه
في دراسه غريبه توصل بحث هنا في جامعه
البوستن الامريكيه الى احتمال وجود صله
بين ارتفاع درجات الحراره وتزايد حوادث
العنف في المدن الامريكيه وذلك على دور
تزايد معدل حوادث اطلاق النار خلال
السنوات الاخيره الدراسه وجدت ان 7% من
حوادث اطلاق النار تقع خلال فترات تشهد
درجات الحراره تفوق تفوق المعدلات
الطبيعيه وانا مناطق الشمال الشرقيه
والغرب الاوسط الامريكي هي التي تشهد اكبر
زياده في حوادث العنف المسلح في الايام
التي تسجل درجات حراره فوق المحتاد
[موسيقى]
نختم من بريطانيا حيث كشف بنك انجلترا عن
اول عملات ورقيه تحمل سوره الملك تشارلز
الثالث الذي اعتلى العرش بعد وفاه والدته
الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه في سبتمبر الماضي
العملات الجديده المصنوعه من البوليمر
ستطرح للتداول اعتبارا من منتصف العام
2024 فيما اعلن المصرف البريطاني المركزي
ان صوره الملك ستظهر على النماذج الحاليه
للاوراق النقديه من الفئات الاربعه وهي
خمسه وعشره 25
جنيها استرلينيا من دون اي تعديل اخر في
تصميمها